cut sumoto to one of the guys I have
played three times I want all three
games but macadam villa in a somewhat
shaky form at the moment I hope that I
keep the series nevertheless it's um
yeah this shaky formas due to my my work
at the moment I'm currently doing the
finishing touches on my book and when
you see the video it will be it's it's a
bit it already to the to the publisher
but I'm on the last day actually and I'm
recording this just to keep the steady
flow of videos going but not totally
focused on on playing the games I have
to admit that it's a little bit
difficult when you do like 10 12 15
hours in in one go on on a chess book
and then you you play play blitz videos
or play blitz games you know playing the
videos okay I think this one but I'm not
sure this is one of those tricky lines
where black is activating no it's not
okay there are lines where he can play
Queen before I was expecting this
actually
and so on for activity this is always a
little bit tricky
yeah this looks like white is on the
back foot but I have f4 yeah f4 it's a
kind of move where like sometimes can
get in a piece sacrifice or something
maybe see that I prevent d5 with this
for the moment hmm interesting
yeah okay without f4 I cannot really
play this I have to kick his night away
and just try to play with this maybe 95
immediately what's interesting
maybe but okay it's not going away this
possibility at least this is what I hope
okay let's protect g3 oops that five is
a pre move please I wanted to point that
there v square this was an idea
f5 keeping I mean the teching the the
bishop here it's still an idea this may
be really moves like d5 instance and
such now let's let's play some some some
solid moves here
Chen tending before and so on we do you
want to play a quite a style of of game
katsumoto
before has an idea to if possible take
on c5 and if he retakes with the Jeep
horn I have a central majority and can
go 95 e 5 and so on some it's often a
good positional idea the the problem
with my position is the slight lack of
coordination I mean not coordination is
wrong but it is when you push all those
points you will invariably have some
weaknesses in your on the back of your
position let's say like d3 is completely
weak he has nothing to put there but d3
b2 is all kind of weak even the king is
slightly slightly weakened here with f4
and so on so it's often a tricky tricky
thing to play this type of position ok
I'm going to put put this on d5 trying
to gain the c-4 square for the knight so
after a capture on c5 I want to play
Knight c4
that's what I want to do here night see
Frances this is where you want where you
want to go in the can of this kind of
structure the ideal night placement
I can almost I can almost play there
what about G for here G for night back
then I take I can take on deform hmm and
then Knight to c6 maybe I really don't
have the time to figure it out
completely it splits I don't want to
take on d4 positionally speaking from a
strategic point of view I don't want to
do this but it looks really good
tactically this thing Knight coming to
c6
couldn't take d4 because of 94 check
yeah he's going for the Queen sacrifice
this is something that I anticipated or
at least thought possible he gained some
some coordination that way how do I do
that hmm I don't I cannot really a check
on the G file it's not possible let me
put this on see to how this is was this
was a nice idea get the night there okay
this is still a good a good place
bishop will come to f3 anyway rook g8
Bishop f3 this kind of thing and my
trump card is of course the the D pawn
so let's let's enter
intending DS 67 yeah the bishop is
stopping the D pawn that's the idea so
let's let's get this pawn rollin Queen
b7 or rook b7 Queen c7 Esther that's
what I wanted you he might I can I can
do this no h7 is falling
now there's no defense now I think the
screen the screen sacrifice was
ultimately insufficient but it was a it
was a difficult position I believe I get
to see six with the night hmm not much
fun getting the clock run down or
disconnected you never know
it's not the greatest 3-minute play of
all time it's a really slow rate every
low rating he's probably on time
somewhat I'm not sure this was a
ragequit or anything it could have been
a real disconnection problem yeah this
is this kind of opening is very very
difficult to play it is giving wide a
huge advantage in space space but as I
mentioned it's a somewhat shaky position
i RG 4 was interesting well ok I just
wanted to play safe and simple if
possible
so something like this yeah I mean white
is probably better but not not easy to
play this was really trying to play
simple chess but it's good now yeah I
will get the thing is now every pawn
transformation here on c5 is good for me
B takes D takes gives me two strong
central pawns I can't even play e5 then
supported by the bishops and if he takes
and BTX we get to the we get the game
position
we're just is very nice for me he went
there which kind of invites what
happened by the way this is also very
strong moves as pointed out by stockfish
very strong him this is probably not bad
either
yeah and yeah yeah he probably has to
move the Queen and then I'm getting in
there something like this
so the thing what I don't like is I
don't have a dark squared bishop anymore
so I'm really weak on the dark squares
but this is a super strong piece and I'm
getting in e5 probably it will be tricky
with little time but it's a very good
position simply because the knight on c6
is so strong okay I hope you like this
thanks for watching